some things are inevitable in life
anything that can go wrong will go wrong
the simple answer is usually the correct
one
and if you want to play a competitive
tactical shooter you must start each
half
with a pistol so whether you like it or
not if you want to play games like
counter-strike or valorant you're gonna
be restricted to using handguns for at
least two rounds to just snacks does
find one let's not leave him out of this
the big apple and snacks is hungry he's
got one kill already on the usp
low hp as well on guardian and flame
he's trying to bait them out trying to
get them into one-on-ones as he dances
back and forth between the box what a
shot on simple oh guardian bye-bye and
it's on the flamey he's tapped in flame
he's got a big
what in god's name is that from stacks
unbelievable
but as i said it's only two rounds of
the map if you just can't get the hang
of them it's okay focus on the more
important things like rifles and scoped
weapons it's not like pistol rounds
decide the match
or do they you see even though pistol
rounds do seem kind of quotidian and
forgettable when you first start to play
these games
many veterans of the scene have often
speculated whether or not they actually
have too great of an impact on the game
others don't see it as a problem at all
and even excel at their pistol round
proficiency you've said it enough times
and we've definitely seen it prove that
dennis is extremely good on these
pistols to start that momentum off fast
play very fast play and there it is oh
my god dennis on cue on point all three
kills again
i'm done don't even buy guns just this
guy could use a usb for the entire game
and i would be convinced
because g2 certainly has to be convinced
it might be
with an absolutely perfect round
but if the latter is true
then
why
why is the pistol round so important and
when it comes to valorant versus cs go
in which game is the pistol more
important
[Applause]
okay so before we dive into the actual
raw data we should address a term of art
that i'm going to be using commonly
throughout this video
the economy how does a self-sustaining
economy work i don't understand how the
u.s economy works much less a some sort
of a self-sustaining one counter-strike
and valorant are tactical shooters that
include an economic system for buying
weapons and utility at the start of each
round players can use their money to buy
guns getting kills and playing the
objective add to your personal economy
as well as your teams letting you
purchase better items or just padding
your wallet for the next round now in
order to keep things balanced at the
beginning of each half every player
spawns with the same amount of money and
in both games you are only given enough
to either upgrade your pistol get a
couple of pieces utility or snag some
body armor depending on how you want to
play the round but why
why have an economic system to begin
with why not start with a larger sum of
money
well
it's what makes cs go and valorant what
they are that economic complexity
is what makes the games worth playing um
it's a cool idea maybe this is as well
what is going on here oh yes the pulse
that the pull stack the pull boost the
pool party
oh fy fy pull party that was the
favorite hello
[Laughter]
starting off with as little as they
already do helps add to the already
existing asymmetry in the game
and this is especially true in
counter-strike in cs certain weapons are
exclusive to whichever side you're on
terrorists get the ak-47 for instance
and counter terrorists get the m4 or
m4a1s in a similar fashion ts start with
the glock and cts start with the usp and
both weapons operate very differently
now it's more common for tees to upgrade
their firepower since the range of the
glock is kind of bad but since the glock
does have a huge mag and boasts insane
running accuracy it might be in your
best interest to either grab a smoke or
some flashes if your plan is to sprint
onto sight but most people love the usp
that you get on ct side since it's great
for holding angles and taking long range
engagements it's become an iconic gun in
its own right thanks to its propensity
for popping melons and the sweet sweet
gush noise it makes when it does usb and
gaze in a normal spot that's a very nice
shot from here man he will allow him to
run distraction gain what are you doing
that's four kills from him monstrous
there's the ace as well that was nasty
from start to finish that was absolutely
disgusting some believe the usp is
actually a bit overpowered while others
claim rightfully in my opinion that the
glock is actually better than the usp in
virtually every respect except at range
and that the glock's detractors just
don't know how to utilize it to its full
potential as twist tries to do
everything to defend the bomb two kills
for him knows that he can pull but he's
going to fight first he's got that twist
he's going to try
no molotov to use there's a smoke on the
side anyway forest has picked up one can
he go any better than that he knows he's
been playing oh right now
[Applause]
that was ridiculous
with that being said is one better than
the other and does it make attacking or
defending easier statistically speaking
defending is easier but that's to be
expected since most maps and in some
sense the game are both just inherently
ct-sided at the pgl major for instance
the usp made up for 5.3 percent of all
kills while the glock only made up for
three percent
but keep in mind both ancient and the
newly renovated dust too are pretty ct
sided and they're both in the pool now
so do with that information what you'd
like but this is where valorant comes in
you see invalorant it is way more common
for players to upgrade their starting
pistols since both teams start with the
same sidearm and different agents offer
different forms of utility a jet buying
a sheriff in the pistol round is
actually way more viable than say a
silver two buying a deagle that yours
truly accidentally picked up in the
middle of a retake thinking it was a
glock
[Music]
my boy kk baller on reddit was even nice
enough to provide some statistics from
masters berlin to further bolster this
argument the classic was used most often
in pistol rounds at 47
and had the highest win rate with 52
percent which at the highest most
organized level of play makes sense
since players of that caliber are more
likely to opt for some utility over
firepower what's interesting however is
that the ghost was right behind it it
was picked 46 of the time and had a 49
win rate on top of that the sheriff was
only bought two percent of the time but
had the highest kill rate sitting at 98
so don't get too salty when you get one
tapped by a sheriff right after full
buying since its conversion rate
is
like
really good sometimes i don't want to
buy a vandal sometimes i would just
rather just buy a sheriff i feel like
the sheriff is the biggest culprit of
these thrifty rounds now all these
statistics on weaponry are interesting
but they don't answer the question we're
here for how much do pistol rounds
really matter in 2017 three clicks
philip did an excellent video addressing
reddit user fizzy cock's research on
pistol round statistics from big events
fizzycock found that 68 of the time that
a team won both pistol rounds they would
go on to win the map
valve even responded and said that they
got a similar number when looking at
over 2 million competitive matches so
yes pistol rounds clearly matter but
that data was from 2016 and we wanted to
see if anything had actually changed
since then so i took a look at the most
recent pgl major and found out that in
games where a team won both pistols they
went on to win the game roughly 77 of
the time now that percentage might be a
little lower if you wanted to remove
overtime wins
but still the answer is yes pistols are
still extremely important again all
three of them in fact going in that
direction the only one who's not is olaf
who's back towards ct on top of the box
though it's elise he's got three and
he's looking over on fourth that is
incredible from him to win out the
pistol for liquid now what about
valorent well if we look back at the
stats from masters berlin the teams that
won both pistol rounds went on to win
the map 83 of the time and the champions
that percentage was
77.5
that is [ __ ] insane and it brings us
to our next question
why does this happen the short answer
is the economy all right i will buy it
it'll be good for the economy the long
answer
well that's out of my pay grade you
gotta
go ask colton and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
look i'm not gonna pretend to know more
than dimitri about any tactical shooter
i'm a halo and apex guy so what do i
know
math and spreadsheets and these
economies tend to get pretty complicated
so that's probably going to come in
handy and we're going to start with
counter-strike let's start simple
winning by killing the enemy team gets
you three thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars and thirty five hundred dollars
if the win comes courtesy of detonating
or defusing the bomb any kills you got
in the round unless you bought a zeus
the cz or manage a knife kill net you
three hundred dollars each but here's
where things get a bit more complicated
if the t side plants the bomb they get
an extra three hundred for their win and
an extra eight hundred dollars if they
end up losing the round while one ct
gets three hundred dollars for the
defuse and each team gets 1900 base for
a loss
following me so far
good let's take a look at three
practical examples first if the t's
manage to plant but the cts wipe them
and get the defuse then the difference
in average income is one thousand one
hundred and sixty dollars in favor of
the cts if either team wins simply by
killing the other the average income is
sixteen hundred dollars in favor of the
winning team lastly if the t side kills
all five cts and gets the bomb plant the
average income is 2300 in their favor
even just at a glance it's pretty clear
that the t's have more to gain and less
to lose in the pistol round but the
win-loss earnings aren't the only place
that this shows up the rifles the core
weapons in any competitive cs go match
are on average
338 dollars more expensive for the cts
meaning every buy round is costing them
more in pure firepower
not to mention the 400 diffuser if you
don't want to be a loser and the extra
200 on incendiary grenades valorent on
the other hand works in a similar but
simplified way you get 3 000 credits for
winning 300 credits for planting no
extra credits for diffusing and 200
credits per kill no matter what weapon
you got the kill with so let's take a
look at the same three practical
examples from before
if the attacking team plants gets wiped
and the defenders defuse then the
average income is 1000 credits in the
defender's favor if either team wins by
killing the other then the average
income is 1300 credits in the winning
team's favor if the attackers manage to
plant and kill all the defenders then
the average income is 1600 credits in
their favor so what can we actually
learn from all these numbers while the
economic swing does seem to be more
pronounced in cs go teams at the top of
both games managed to convert the next
round after winning the pistol about 80
percent of the time
in other words
a lot in both games if you manage to win
both pistol rounds you're likely taking
home somewhere between four and six
rounds just based on those two wins
alone especially if the enemy team
decides to force buy loses the next
round and decimates their own economy
ultimately winning the pistol can either
jump-start the defender's economy or
build a strong early lead for the
attackers winning just one pistol round
can change the tides of a game more than
any other round but i'll throw it back
to dimitri before i answer his next
question for him too and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about what next wait what what next
question
oh right in which game are pistol rounds
more important well obviously if we just
look at the numbers from earlier
77.5 percent to 83 percent is larger
than 68 to 77
so winning both pistol rounds does seem
to be slightly more important and
valorent than cs go but it's actually
more complicated than that to get the
real answer we need to look at
you guessed it
the economy guess what grows the economy
to win a match of cs you have to get 16
rounds in valorant it's only 13 meaning
if you do what colton mentioned and win
six rounds the enemy team has an even
larger hill to climb so in valorant if
you go on to win the game after winning
those six rounds you've effectively won
at least 46 of your rounds while the
other team is at an economic
disadvantage now technically since you
almost never have to double save and
valorent the total number of rounds you
can win off a pistol is usually cut to
four however that's assuming that the
enemy team is going to save the second
round you see youtuber bugsy the bean
discovered something very interesting
when looking at buying patterns pro
teams convert their second round forces
36 of the time compared to just a 4
conversion rate of full ecos what proves
that force buying is worth it though is
this following statistic if you lose the
pistol then save you're only expected to
get 4.7 rounds that half forcing second
round instead of saving raises your
expected rounds to 5.5
yes his research shows us that saving
might not be the play and teams that
force by in the second round win more
often
by a lot and we actually spoke to ethos
to see if the anecdotal evidence of a
pro corresponded with the data that bugs
either being on earth i've seen so many
thrifties in polar and you don't see
that many ecos in cs go you don't see
that like is very like how often do you
see glocks when against aks uh like that
this doesn't happen really uh but in
this game classics are the best thing to
ever exist
uh the frenzy is busted the ghost
against rifle is really good too don't
even get me started on sheriffs and then
like other things as well like abilities
now this doesn't suggest that pistol
rounds are any less important than
valerians just that saving after a loss
might not be in your best interest and
that maybe just maybe the reason that
pistol rounds have such an effect on the
outcome of a map is because pros aren't
forcing enough so yes right now pistol
rounds are still technically more
important in valorant than in cs
but the game is just over a year old and
knowing riot the meta will change
constantly pistol rounds will never go
away and will likely always be extremely
impactful to the outcome of both games
but are we just okay with that if we
look at the pgl major stats again you
can see that the op ak and m4 still make
up the bulk of the kills we saw so it's
not like the pistols take away from the
viewing experience as a whole pistols
might not be the sexiest part of the
game's arsenal but popping off in a
pistol round is always satisfying
whether it's the gush of the usp or the
sound of a major scale in valorum
[Music]
it actually sounds more like an e minor
scale to me but
close enough dimitri remember pistol
rounds need to be as important as they
are they reset the half create swings
and momentum and if valve or riot were
to nerf them or restructure them
they'd run the risk of turning pistol
rounds as we know them
into kind of a gimmick but knowing how
much you stand to lose makes even the
very first round feel as important as
the last it also makes eco rounds that
much more exciting and special if and
when they do happen and without the
importance of the pistol round we run
the risk of devaluing what makes
counter-strike and valoran so special
the economy 2020
the economy
in shambles
2021 the economy is in
shambles
so telling yourself that you're just not
a pistol player
ain't a good excuse they are an integral
part of the game and should be respected
as such and yes they do affect the
rounds that follow but part of the
appeal of these games is that you always
need to be thinking 10 steps ahead of
your enemy you can even take all of this
away and say that stats don't matter and
that the better team will always win
but i think three clicks phillip put it
best maybe we're trying to find a
solution that isn't needed changing
things for change's sake if valve stats
are to be believed and pistol rounds are
no more random than any other then why
does it matter if it affects the next
two brands as well sure 68 of double
pistol wins result in victory but does
that perhaps make the 23 of losses all
the more valuable to experience and to
spectate
perhaps clawing back victory in the
second or third rounds against all odds
makes the counter track experience more
enthralling than one where the tide
changes every round for balance's sake
let's
get this bread let's cop this crust
attain the yeast attain the yeast breath
we need to take yet another look at you
guessed it
the
economy the economy
the economy the economy
to industry to industry lots the
gentleman's agreement a gentleman's
agreement huzzah